[Musique]
nous sommes le jeudi 26 janvier 2017
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
édition du 7 8 les invités rencontres
avec celles et ceux qui font l actualité
dans les yvelines
voici lé titre alexandre morlaix nous
parlons avec lui dans un instant du rpf
c'est le secrétaire départemental de
cette formation il nous parlera de son
ambition pour la relancer justement
également tout à l'heure vous entendrez
marie-laure couderc c'est la présidente
de la société et des cinémas de l'oua et
ce thème nous vous expliquera pourquoi
leur achètent aujourd'hui avec l'aide de
l'ugc le cinéma le cyrano à versailles
elle nous dira surtout ce qui va changer
dans les prochains mois pour ses clients
alexandre barrelet bonsoir bon si vous
êtes le secrétaire départemental donc du
rpf rpf pour rassemblement pour la
france c'est un parti de droite droite
républicaine à sensibilité gaulliste
partenaires des républicains et de lui
dit
la première question est simple
finalement être gaulliste aujourd'hui ça
signifie quoi
byte gaulliste passer avant tout est de
droite c'est aimer le terrain et mais la
population s'investir dans des projets
locaux soutenir les entreprises le
domaine associatif naître avec les
groupes de défense des consommateurs
et puis c'est surtout j'allais dire un
état d'esprit c'est la volonté de gagner
la vente et la volonté d'être avec le
peuple pour ba relancer un petit peu de
renouveau parce que la france en a bien
besoin
actuellement m gaulliste aujourd'hui sa
part le plus grand nombre aux plus
jeunes aussi
oui bien sûr parce que ben heureusement
encore à l'école on en reparle faut pas
oublier que c'est le général de gaulle
qui a lancé la première du gaullisme
d'ailleurs il a été à l'origine de la
création notre parti qui était le rpf de
première génération n'a eu ensuite le
rpf de deuxième génération qui a été
lancé par charles pasqua dont qui s'est
orientée 1
rpf à eux ensuite on a eu droit à
christian vanneste qui est parti lui
malheureusement vers des alliances avec
les extrêmes avec l'extrême droite
ça lui a valu un conseil de l'ensemble
des cadres dirigeants du parti qui l'ont
effectivement démis de ses fonctions et
ont nommé igor kurek l'actuel président
de la quatrième génération président de
ce parti pour nous recentrer
effectivement sur la droite républicaine
le gaullisme comme vous l'avez dit petit
parti le conservatisme et puis aussi un
petit peu de souverainisme parce qu'on a
besoin sur des questions d'ordre
européenne aussi de relancer certains
débats notamment quand on parle de la
politique agricole du soutien aux
grandes entreprises françaises ou alors
question de sécurité je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce doit être mon peuple
de décider quand on va revenir sur
quelques points de votre programme
justement les idées que vous portez mais
aujourd'hui pourquoi relancer ce
mouvement le rpf
vous l'avez dit le mouvement est né avec
le général de gaulle dont il ya quelques
quelques années d'expérience derrière
mais pourquoi avoir décidé de le
relancer le relancer dans les yvelines
et pourquoi ne pas vous être souciés
tout simplement adhérer aux républicains
par exemple alors le rassemblement
existe déjà il avait été relancée sur la
quatrième génération qu novembre 2015
pour preuve on a actuellement gérés dire
un délégué national aux fédérations qui
s'appelle franck barbet qui est élu
communautaire élu municipal avec la
majorité les républicains à grasse on a
également notre porte parole brise blazy
qui était lui même un élu municipal les
élus de la communauté de communes de
l'agglomération de béziers contre robert
ménard donc effectivement qu'on a ce
cette volonté de combat oui on est dans
l'alliance oui on est aussi dans
l'autonomie parce qu'on a envie aussi de
de montrer aux français une autre façon
de s'exprimer
notre façon de
vivre la droite parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya beaucoup de gens qui s'expriment au
nom du gaullisme et qui montrent le
contraire des préceptes qui arrive quand
été diffusé par le général de gaulle et
je pense notamment à nicolas dupont
aignan ou à d'autres d'autres personnes
qui aujourd'hui côtoient les extrêmes
plutôt que l'origine fondamental de nos
partis du rpf aujourd'hui apporte quoi
aux républicains et reviens à ma
question pourquoi ne pas adhérer pour
vous par exemple dans votre parcours
personnel directement aux républicains
tout simplement par choix personnel
parce qu'aujourd'hui mais les
républicains ont aussi leur façon de
voir les choses on voit aussi
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
candidats qui se présentent avec une
colonie de casquettes parents il faut
être maire député conseiller régional
conseiller général nous conçoit la
politique de manière plus local de
manière plus simple on va s'attacher à
une fonction on va la mener à bien avec
les habitants et aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut revoir la politique sur ses
fondamentaux faut être avec le peuple
il faut être à son écoute il faut
arrêter d'être dans la pédagogie pour
expliquer ce qu'il faut faire pour
réussir ce qu'aujourd'hui les politiques
doivent un petit peu réexaminer le fond
de leur pensée est plus à l'écouté des
concitoyens mais vous parler du cumul
des mandats aux républicains ya
également des des cumulards finalement
ben oui mais heureusement ça vous
intéresse pas de soutenir néanmoins le
candidat des républicains pour la
prochaine présidentielle
françois fillon n'est que sur la partie
députés donc on va dire qu'il se
consacre à un mandat précis donc c'est
quand même déjà là pour lui oui mais
pour lequel son parti dans son parc
alors nous aujourd'hui le rpf on est
dans l'association le partenariat oui
avec les républicains pas
systématiquement puisqu'on viennent
aussi notre propre politique dans notre
coin au niveau local on a monté des
listes pour les municipales on va
présenter une vingtaine de candidats
pour les législatives dont je fais
partie je serais quand même d'as sur la
troisième attention des yvelines
et comme je le rencontrais souvent de la
part de mes concurrents mais concourant
son candidat contre henri guaino et moi
je suis candidat pour être le
représentant de la circonscription pour
être à côté des associations des élus
locaux des concitoyens des entreprises
parce que c'est quand même nous tissu
économique il faut défendre et
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que les
gens sont plus donc dans des batailles
d'étiquettes dans delà de la volonté de
se mettre en avant
on doit avoir une obligation de résultat
aujourd'hui je pense que un député c'est
comme dans une entreprise il doit être
rémunéré à hauteur de la tenue de ses
engagements et par rapport à des
résultats concrets qui doit se mesurer à
la fois sur le terrain en accompagnant
les élus locaux et les associations au
niveau national pour prouver
effectivement que la profession de foi
qu'on engage elle sera tenue
c'est pas juste un discours électoraux
rayess pour gagner des voix en deux mots
philippe brillault qui souhaitent se
présenter sous l'étiquette des
républicains puisque henri guaino ne
sera visiblement pas investi par son
parti après ses propos contre françois
fillon félibrée au maire du chesnay qui
se présente pour être député vous serez
face à lui je serais façade hui je vais
très gelé bien connu puisque on a
travaillé ensemble à l'époque à l'ump
j'allais dire y défend une certaine
opinion effectivement c'est quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup aujourd'hui de demanda en
termes de représentation les conseiller
territorial il est maire il est délégué
ump de la 3e république un de la 3e
circonscription
il est aussi membre de syndicats
intercommunaux de la communauté du grand
parc vgp versailles je pense que si on
doit faire les choses bien on doit se
consacrer à un mandat c'est ce que
demandent aujourd'hui les français donc
moi je souhaite aussi bonne chance parce
que nous avons mené des combats ensemble
en politique
j'allais dire la concurrence est saine
c'est quelque chose de très positif en
politique à partir du moment où on
conçoit vraiment j'ai à dire la
politique sur un but de développement
des concitoyens et part sur un titre
pearson le point prioritaire de votre
programme
on aura l'occasion d'en parler lors des
différents un débat que nous organisons
dans les prochaines semaines mais
certains points moi je suis dans la
défense on va dire de l'égalité
salariale hommes-femmes qui n'est
toujours pas respectée au sein de
certaines sociétés et il faut un moment
donné prendre les dispositions sur des
je pense des suppression d'allègements
fiscaux pour pour des sociétés
je suis dans la réinstauration de la
demi part vieillesse qui a été retiré
par l'ump et qui aujourd'hui manque
terriblement et fait défaut à énormément
de boeuf et de veuves qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent dans une certaine misère
sociale et c'est inadmissible
aujourd'hui de tolérer de retirer
jaillir du pouvoir d'achat aux
françaises et aux français et on doit le
remettre sur l'ordre du jour une toute
dernière question très rapidement le rpf
dans les yvelines aujourd'hui représente
quoi
aujourd'hui basset d'un nouveau
mouvement c'est un nouvel élan d'une
dizaine d'adhérents n'est reparti depuis
janvier on va être l'alternative aux
législatives va être un nouveau courant
de pensée pour les municipales on est là
pour apporter j'allais dire un nouveau
regard sur la vie locale la vie
citoyenne et l'avantagé qu'aujourd'hui
on est de droite la droite ne se limite
pas aux républicains au parti chrétien
démocrate au modem ou autres partis qui
se disent de ses sensibilités
aujourd'hui je pense que les françaises
et les français surtout les yvelinois
ont le droit à une nouvelle
représentation qu'ils auraient plus
proche du terrain merci d'être venus en
plateau nommé relais de ce mouvement
vous relancer le rpf merci à vous on
quitte la politique pour un autre
univers à présent le cyrano de
versailles le roxane ce sont deux salles
emblématiques de versailles de salles
qui vont connaître quelques changements
dans les prochains mois elles ont en
effet été racheté les précisions
avec cette interview menée par camille
lambert ce cinéma pour moi c'est le
cinéma de mes grands parents de mon
et même de mes arrière grands parents
donc c'était important pour moi que ce
que ça reste un patrimoine familial et
que ça reste un cinéma aussi donc quand
j'ai parlé commencé à parler avec mon
oncle qui lui effectivement commencé à
préparer la transmission de ces cinémas
il est tout à fait pour et une
transmission familiale ça lui allait
très bien simplement financièrement
c'était un petit peu difficile donc j'ai
pas pu porter cette opération tout seul
et il a fallu que je trouve un associé
et mon choix s'est porté sur ugc sujet
c'est pour nous c'est aussi la famille
alors effectivement pas forcément une
famille de consanguinité
mais une famille professionnelle c'est à
dire que mon grand père a longtemps
dirigé l'ugc a travaillé longtemps avec
le président actuel et quelque part je
retrouve mes valeurs et également voilà
donc c'était un choix assez naturel pour
moi
de choisir ses partenaires là en fait on
a créé une société ensemble j'essaie
plus moi personne personne physique et
j'en ai la présidence voila mail
opérationnelle est assurée par toutes
les équipes que j'ai c'est à dire que
finalement ce sera un cinéma ugc avec
une enseigne d'essayer la carte
illimitée tout devint tout leur savoir
faire
moi je fais que des cinéma de
centre-ville et si ce que défend et
c'est à dire sans des cinémas de
proximité qui doivent proposer les films
le film grand public aussi un les films
grand public pour les gens qui peuvent
pas ou qui ne veulent pas aller en
voiture sur l'extérieur ou dans des gros
machin pardon mais dès qu'on voit les
grands multiplexes la grande force du
cirano c'est son emplacement sa
connaissance les versailles et
connaissent le cyrano il a une face à de
magnifiques il faut il faut vraiment le
préserver ça en revanche au niveau
confort voilà les il ya des shows au
niveau accessibilité au niveau
accessibilité pmr au niveau sécurité
incendie là il ya des choses des choses
qu'ils voient des choses qui se voit pas
nous sommes associés avec marie-laure
couderc donc pour acheter ensemble au
sein d'une structure commune pour
racheter le cyrano étant précisé que
l'accord avec marie-laure c'est que là
j'allais dire le le concept éditorial
l'évolution du cirano sa gestion au
quotidien toute la stratégie et sera
mené par le g7 le l'ambition si vous
voulez très clairement c'est de faire du
cirano
il ya un cinéma de référence du
centre-ville de versailles
donc ça c'est ma quelle histoire mack a
un nom il ya une forte notoriété
voilà c'est un cinéma qui a j'allais
dire de notre point de vue un gros
potentiel
sous réserve bien sûr vous l'avez vu
sous réserve donc d'être j'allais dire
remis j'allais dire un petit peu aux
normes des cinémas d'aujourd'hui
critères qui bénéficie d'un très bel
emplacement belle architecture de
volumes très intéressant voilà donc
notre ambition c'est ça alors ça ça a
deux conséquences
une conséquence j'allais dire en termes
de programmation c'est à dire assumer de
référence de centre ville
un cinéma donc généralistes ouvert aussi
bien aux films familiaux qu'au cinéma
art et essai nous allons probablement
intensifier la version originale non
cinéma parce que nous pensons que la
soude versailles sa sociologie
l'importance de la population
international également qui vit dans la
région le justifie voilà et puis nous
allons jeudi réfléchir et développer un
projet de rénovation globale du site
nous avons plusieurs j'allais dire
scénario dense et mais l'objectif global
si vous voulez c'est une restructuration
lourde du cinéma à le dire c'est une
restructuration lourde toutes les salles
seront concernés par la par le projet
les circulations donc alors après vous
dire exactement si vous voulez à la fin
à combien de salles est ce qu'on restera
huit salles est ce qu on demande
beaucoup montré un peu la capacité en
nombre d'écrans et serra ce sont des
scénarios à l'étude
pas encore de projet définitif de
décider non non parce qu'il ya plusieurs
possibilités et donc ça dépendra
j'allais dire des conditions j'allais
dire technique architecturale il ya
plusieurs scénarios aux architectes
travaillent mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que c'est une refonte en
profondeur de la totalité du cinéma
aujourd'hui c'est un cinéma qui j'allais
dire dans son jus des années 70
fin des années 70 voilà c'est ça qu'il
faut réactualiser refaire des salles de
avec une grande qualité et puis il faut
probablement revoir les espaces communs
et voilà l'ambition c'est vraiment d'en
faire le sima de référence de
centre-ville de toute la région
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
ce soir on se retrouve à lundi avec
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département
[Musique]